uh well hey I gotta say man um I'm glad
you're here because I mean you obviously
there was a huge what are we talking
about man there was a huge tragedy that
happened in Monterey Park yo bro I was
there I know that's why I said I'm glad
you were here physically because you you
were there I was shaking I was shaking
bro that I I mean I would when I say I
was there I wasn't there like it didn't
happen like right there in front of me
but I was eating at a restaurant like
right next to that board on Garvey and
whatever right uh so whatever Ballroom I
didn't even know it was a ballroom I was
eating at the restaurant right there we
got out of that restaurant at like 10
15. 10 15 we paid everything I walked
out the door at like 10 15. we got to
about 10 15 10 18 I got to my car the
shot started going off at like 10 20 25
that's when the first police report went
on went on you know what I'm saying and
I was out there and I didn't know I was
driving to another party I was driving
to a party and then when we got to the
party the girl I was with was like yo do
you see this we were just we were just
here we just left it and I was like what
I went in a party for like maybe 10
minutes out and she she was so freaked
out that she wanted to leave right and
she so we left we got back I went home
and I'm just like
like minutes and and you know what I'm
saying like I felt like I escaped
because
I didn't know it was in a ballroom so at
the time I thought he was just like
shooting in the street right so I felt
like I escaped that but then I also know
if that's going on you're gonna go up in
there and try to
no I mean if if it's inside I'm not
gonna run in there but even if he if
he's in the street right shooting
I'ma react bro like like you know what
I'm saying like I'm gonna react my life
and I'm not gonna allow anybody to just
like [__] right do whatever like I'm
gonna be on the news too I'm gonna be on
the news right along with him but if
it's like inside somewhere I'm not
running up there and like doing all that
but if it's in the vicinity like say I'm
in Walmart and somebody is doing that
and I'm you know what I'm saying I have
the uh you know the capabilities of
reacting I'm gonna react right because I
don't know if you're gonna turn around
and shoot me or if you're gonna shoot a
kid or whatever so you know
um I I felt like I escaped that bro I
ain't gonna lie and and God Rest God
bless those people man and then there
was another one yesterday in San
Francisco right right in the Bay Area
yeah in the Bay Area there was another
one another [__] Chinese dude shoot
up a bunch of Chinese dude I don't know
what the hell is going on I don't know
what this is but it's it sounds fishy to
me man it sounds interesting it's just
that it's like it's like a sick
coincidence because this no no the story
is like the one in Monterey Park he the
story is do you know are you familiar
with I'm not sure like I I saw the video
of the guy getting taken down and then
obviously the guy killed himself in the
white van in Torrance but I'm not sure
like I don't know anything he went from
Monterey Park he shot that up he got in
his call he left he drove to Alhambra
which is another heavily Asian another
heavily Asian community
and he went into another spot so that
what I've read was that he went to the
first spot because his ex-girlfriend or
whatever was in the party and he wasn't
invited to some some crazy stuff like
that right and then he shot it up then
he left and he went to Alhambra to shoot
up another spot but that doesn't make
sense to me because like if you wasn't
invited to one party and you shot it up
why are you going to another spot you
wasn't invited there either like what
the hell they're also very far apart
right they're also very far apart so now
he goes in there but he get he he get
wrestles to do one of the young people
that was at the door wrestles him for
the gun you see it's on video he's he's
taking a gun from him and he's taking
the gun the guy he's just crazy shout
out to that guy yeah shout out to him
whoever he is and he tries to like fight
he tried to wrestle the gun out of him
he had an opportunity to shoot the man
too I would have I would have smoked the
dude you would have smoked it if I'd
have took the gun from him
and I'm getting you in the leg at least
right right
like yeah he's better than me he's
better than the dude was trying to pick
up a water bottle yeah yeah that shit's
crazy bro so you were like [__] dude
that because like you said if you like
what if you were like sitting there and
you saw a guy walking in with that gun
you'd be like what the [__] like you you
don't know how you're gonna react in
that situation
bro I mean I know how I'm gonna react
yeah I'm saying I ain't gonna say how
I'm gonna react but I will react with
like nah that [__] [__] up bro that's
why that's why you know what I'm saying
I went on my I went on my YouTube
channel and I made a video immediately
and you know people were saying oh you
trying to profit or like get clout over
that incident but no absolutely not
that's not what the [__] I was trying to
do what I was trying to do was make a
video and say hey everybody Whoever has
the ability to get your gun license go
get that [__] like you know what
I'm saying everybody should have their
gun license if you can have it you know
what I'm saying it's only of your sound
yeah California they make it a lot
harder
um but but you can still make it happen
but they've made it easier since the
pandemic yeah you can still make it
happen so that's what I'm saying like I
went on my YouTube channel to tell
people yo go get your gun license
because you never know what now like the
world is so crazy you could be walking
in Walmart somewhere shopping with your
kids and here come this crazy
[__] shooting up you know what
I'm saying and you know you got to
protect yourself and protect your family
by all means so I went on my channel and
tell my people go get your [__] yeah go
get your gun license try you know I mean